ryser winch
combien tomlinson je vais maintenant
vous présenter serge gainsbourg qui pour
vous c'est mieux en smoking voilà j'ai
gagné mon pari
j'ai gagné mon pari voilà whitney
houston serge gainsbourg gainsbarre pour
les intimes
voilà asseyez-vous serge dites lui que
vous l'avez trouvée sublime voilà serge
gainsbourg auriez-vous de ma demande
comment allez-vous baril va bien rien
bercy est un super si ça marche de
marché deux seulement de ces joueurs est
venus ici aujourd'hui 105 me jean yole
hiis ezio a dit que vous êtes très joli
c'est son goût du dinar you are not
gagnent à note cours bat kovacevic au
dolce rien ay cède à world of soccer
oui alors je vais vous traduire non non
non non non loris et johan cruijff
il dit que vous êtes très joli non non
non non non c'est non il a dit ça mais
ça lui arrive devant rien je peux pas
vous traduire ce qu'il a dit il a dit
j'aimerais bien vous auriez wapler pas
du tout j'ai dit jean réduire apaisé il
mais il a dit il a dit tendre enfance y
non non et non
il est normal vous imaginez quand il est
sous ce nom vous inquiétez pas huit mais
non illégal et il est pas vraiment c'est
aussi en est anormal
oui mais on va maintenant super bien sûr
qu'elle est super presse à moscou et
dans la ville rebelle présent tu tes
excuses à 6,6 fun fly voilà il apologize
il s'excuse il s'excuse pas c'est un
grand enfant
il aura pas de cigarettes cela dit ben
alors bon qui m'a convaincu les 10 on
retrouve eddy mitchell d'accord les jeux
si oui oui d'accord jeudi aux fraises à
sévir et ça va peut-être les villes de
continuer de rêver 6 1 voilà qu'est ce
qui m'a fait d'inviter gainsbourg encore
tiens with le prototype donné par
dutronc le voilà en tout cas whitney
houston
elle est pas prête d'oublier champs
elysées je peux vous dire venir non non
ça va jouer ici sur le bretteur
zigzaguant et finit à donne sur situer
dans notre sublime sublime sublime c'est
mieux que superbe
qu'est ce que je vais bien maintenant ah
bah oui je vais eddy mitchell et puis
elle élimine
à
ça s'appelle une initiation un art
majeur devant une initiation par un art
mineur parce que les gones économique
nous on nous met qu'elle est pour le
surréalisme qui vous avait rien dedans
sont mes cigares mekhissi à leurs
abonnés a annoncé béart qui te parle
oui mais pourquoi est ce que ces mineurs
une chanson 5 oui c'est clair si mu
wayne heures tu situera que la peinture
n'a pas besoin d'initiation mais tu as
toujours la chanson comme cela des
initiations pour la pinte pour les arts
majeurs l'architecturé la peinture et la
musique classique et la littérature et
la poésie le easy s'il te plaît ne
faisons pas la poésie
non il n'ya pas d'art mineur et ce n'est
pas la peine sur la chanson en son
honneur
sinon je ne serais pas là tu peux tout
est important même la cuisine c'est un
tu prends du pognon sur le pauvre
servier moi je viens de boer toutes vos
chansons qu'on dirait que ce sont des
choses mineures alors absolument c'est
vrai sauf certaines qui ont frôlé
certaines certaines séquelles mais le
dieu dessus du jeune melody nelson
sur yonne jeu échangent les dernières
chansons de charlotte les bannières
chanson d'isabelle adjani est celle de
jane birkin
il ne pouvait faire
serge gainsbourg et bien j'en ai appris
des choses sur vous grâce à l'un coelho
et franck lhomeau pour les textes et
nadine costa pour les photographier dans
un album intitulé tout simplement
gainsbourg éditions denoël attention
quand je dis album ici et apostrophe
c'est bien un album et c'est bien livre
parce que dans des émissions variété un
album c'est un 33 tours double album des
trois noms là il s'agit vraiment d'un
livre et d'un très beau lit très beau
livre les photos sont superbes et les
textes sont tout à fait intéressant la
vie alors par exemple une chose que j'ai
appris mon job je connais vous
connaissez peut-être pas très bien il ya
des gens qui me connaissent mieux points
en fait j'ai appris par exemple que
votre première ambition votre premier
talent c'était la peinture ça j'étais
très très surpris à quel âge 28 ans même
assez assez tard oui non mais jusqu'à
vous avez quel était le genre de
peinture que faisait gainsbourg et donc
de dessin j'étais craintif
je peux subissent sur venice mme oh
combien de clients très peu d'années
tout ça alors je questionne drôle et les
rôles initiez-vous les peintures et
ensuite je suis passé à peine une
initiation un art majeur devant une
initiation pas un art mineur comme ce
que les gueulards les conneries que nous
faisons nous mais quelle est pour le
surréalisme qui vous avez dans son
messie liga
mekhissi à leurs abonnés alors c'est
béart qui te parle
oui messieurs en quoi ce que ces mineurs
une chanson sans kouici pioneer ses murs
gardner situera que la peinture il n'a
pas besoin d'initiation mécabourg la
chanson tiab soirée initiation pour la
pinte pour les arts majeurs architecture
la peinture et la musique classique et
la littérature et la poésie
il ya peu ici s'il te plaît
ne faisons pas de la poésie non il n'ya
pas d'art mineur et ce n'est pas la
peine de faire de la chanson en sol
mineur
sinon je ne serais pas là tu peux tout
est important même la cuisine c'est
l'âge tu prends du pognon c'est le
pauvre cervelle moi je viens de boer
toutes vos chansons considérer que ce
sont des choses mina allons absolument
c'est vrai sauf certaines et ont frôlé
mission entrepôt chirambo certaines
certaines certaine ces derniers les quel
est le dieu dessus du jeune melody
nelson sur lienne je les emmenais
dernière chanson de charles et diana
chanson d'isabelle adjani celle de jean
bug alors
il ne préfère pas un retour sur
l'actualité d'hier soir cela se passait
sur tf1 à l'antenne l'émission droit de
réponse
michel polac dirige les débats s'il vous
plaît dans ce sens que deux minutes
elle a dit que j'ai dès que je me suis
dégonflé à strasbourg tiède absolue de
demandes la délation car j'ai mis les
parents voilà j'avais le bras comme ça
monsieur jean françois kahn et là on a
la preuve
nous allons alors patience
nous allons passer un peu de musique
avec un stade franchement les un petit
peu de silence de boulleret leurs
écouteurs bascharage et 3 à 20 du mouche
comme finnair comédie sciages de froid
certaines valeurs universelles une
valeur et je bats les c comprend des
chiens comme toujours à sa place et
convainc jamais un loup merde
voulons nous les damnés de la terre on a
le droit de jacques t on vous en mer et
on en meurt jamais en emmerde bord de
mer minutes a dit allaoui qui essayent
de versailles a renvoyé le sujet une
mouche qui s'il vous plaît